Megan Marco has really been in the news
lately she is struggling really
struggling with being a Dutchess it's
heartbreaking to hear her talk
it is yeah I can't imagine being a new
mother and I'm being under that much
scrutiny Megan says actually that the
British tabloids are to blame when I
first met my now husband my friends were
really happy because I'm so happy but my
British friend said to me
I'm sure he's great but you shouldn't do
it because the British tabloids will
destroy your life I never thought that
this would be easy but I thought it
would be fair it's escalated from Megan
being a breath of fresh air
- then suddenly being deemed vulgar to
being called Dutch is difficult other
things we learned from the documentary
Harry and Megan and African journey
Megan's nickname for Harry is H and
those rumors of a royal rift with
brother William it's true
and we see each other as much as we as
much as we used to because we're so busy
but you know it's just as I said it as
brothers you know good days you have bad
days the royal bad blood could have
started when Harry and Megan were dating
it was never that William didn't like
Megan he just kind of wanted how he to
cap slow down a little bit
a new report claims William is worried
about Megan and Harry and that they were
too candid in the documentary Harry did
confess he struggles with his mental
health as for what's next
et has learned the Sussex family is
headed to LA the belief is it that they
are going to be spending Thanksgiving
with Megan's mom at Doria but it's going
to be interesting to see their approach
to spending time in Los Angeles because
of course the tabloid press follows them
there
[Music]
[Applause]